[Music]
hey folks welcome to running a TV
network in the cloud CBS all access on
GCP so before we go into the
nitty-gritty I just want to address a
little background and so I think one of
the confusing things is when you think
about CBS you generally think about the
television network that we are here to
talk about but CBS Interactive is
actually quite a diverse company you
know we as the slide demonstrates were
in the top 10 for traffic you know
nestled right between Disney and Comcast
but our various brands we have close to
40 different businesses under our
umbrella and it drives a tremendous
amount of traffic but today what we're
here to talk about is television so
before we get into it what I want to do
is just talk about at a high level what
we're gonna discuss we're gonna start
off with where we came from and this
includes the TV industry itself what
it's like for us as a business operating
in the cloud some of the challenges and
lessons that we faced from that
transition and finally I want to talk
about probably one of the biggest
television events that happens annually
and that's the Super Bowl so I wanted to
talk about how we handled it what the
traffic looked like and and where we go
with those sort of big tentpole events
so where did we come from CBS has a rich
history in radio and television and
we've done an impressive job moving into
the internet space CBS all access
is the first direct-to-consumer
broadcast offering and we have a lot of
major television events that we support
on our platform the Super Bowl I just
mentioned we also have the Grammys March
Madness that really if you saw this last
championship it was pretty exciting and
we support our own original content as
well on the platform so shows like Star
Trek discovery and The Twilight Zone as
well as one of our bigger offerings
coming back for the third season which
is the good fight so one of the things
that we have to do is that there are
expectations around broadcast and that
is solving that always on or always
ready problem the expectation with with
any media is that it's there 24/7 it's
available and it's on-demand and what
we're faced with is a background of
really high product delivery we've got
about a hundred years of innovation in
the broadcast space already and that's
set the standard for what the
expectations are for a company that is
doing broadcast whether it is through
the traditional broadcast media or
whether it is delivering that content
over the Internet
one of the things that we face is that
we're constantly bombarded by rapid
surges in traffic meaning that we have
to scale up very quickly I've mentioned
some of these tentpole events like the
Grammys or the Superbowl and it can be a
big challenge to scale up so quickly
live sports broadcasts that our sports
team has to deal with and that we're
often dealing with ourselves as I
mentioned the the March Madness the the
championship there was one of the more
exciting events in just the last week so
we get also call-outs for action in
previous years
the Academy of Country Music their top
award the Entertainer of the Year was
decided on CBS com
so that meant a tremendous surge of
activity during the broadcast we're one
minute millions of people would be
watching the show and then the next
millions of people are coming directly
to our website in less than 5 minutes
and then we have the natural cadence of
television so CBS marketing promotes our
premieres finales special events and
this Alldrive can drive a tremendous
amount of traffic to our platform so
where did we come from
and now I talked about the television
broadcasting what I want to talk about
is traditionally our delivery of our
platform so we were in it our own data
center and we had a service-oriented
architecture and what we tried to do is
really abstract each of the layers of
our platform that they could communicate
autonomously and that they were
stateless this allowed us to do
horizontal scaling very easily at each
level of our platform whether that's our
caching layer our front-end layer or
back in so one of the things though is
that we had a single data center we were
not we were not across multiple data
centers and it was a single zone that
comes with some advantages one of the
big advantages is resource
predictability so we're running VM there
in the data center and you know we
generally knew what kind of capacity
that we had and what kind of traffic we
were going to expect predictable change
control in the data center we work with
the systems Operations Group the network
engineering team to schedule any changes
inside of the data
if the load balancers needed to be
swapped out for a hardware refresh we
knew when that was happening and and we
knew we could act accordingly with our
platform the engineering expertise as I
mentioned inside the network group
inside the systems Operations Group we
were able to really effectively leverage
that expertise outside of our
application engineering group and
finally a simple cost forecasting
weather it was Hardware refreshes or
models based on traffic growth we knew
what to expect in the data center every
year through capital expenditures so
what were the drivers for the cloud what
why did we move from a model that was
fairly predictable that was easy to
maintain and we had a lot of expertise
in so one of them was the business
expectations as our application and the
all access product grew there was an
expectation for us to reach larger and
larger audiences and one of the things
is that we didn't want to leave any
money on the table when it came to
growth so we wanted to make sure that as
we were expanding we were capturing
audience and we were delivering the
product that that audience expected we
wanted to maintain feature parity with
our competitors for good or bad Netflix
is the standard in the space and we we
want to show that our product was a
premium product and it can stand up to
any of the players in the marketplace so
what were the technical considerations
I've already mentioned that we had a
data center and that's the single point
of failure so we had one pipe going in
and that same pipe going out if that
goes down our entire platform goes down
also
fixed capacity we only had so much space
and virtualization inside of a single
inside of a single data center can only
deliver so much capacity and at the time
when we made the decision to move to the
cloud we were reaching that capacity the
other part of it is that while the
benefits of predictability are good
there's a real long procurement process
to get no Hardware swapped in and out
moving to the cloud eliminates a lot of
those problems and finally having that
slowed capacity single point of failure
and that long procurement process where
we're trying to get updated hardware in
place it does slow down the application
development process ideally you want to
decouple infrastructure from application
development all right thank you Jason so
operating in the cloud it's for us it
was really more about organization we
had massive cultural changes within
within cbsi as both essential group as
well as a as well as within our our
vertical be use so we spend a lot of
time investing in our teams to you know
upskill them introduce them to new
technologies send them to the right
training training programs you know for
us just taking a step back we're really
looking at you know it's just a year ago
and to some degree is still a little bit
today we have a traditional operations
team you know you got one side of the
team that's heavily focused on systems
engineering and on the other side you
got the application team that's you know
constantly trying to rev and build out
new new products to meet whatever
business demand whatever whatever the
business might be so the problem was it
was also separated by a wall of
compliance you know you have one side
that says hey
don't get rude access and you get the
other sizes come on give me rude accents
I need to do this really quick but my
product owner wants me to get this out
the door really like tomorrow so we had
to kind of take a step back when we went
to the cloud and look at where the
engineering boundaries are going to be
you know we we like docker
docker was cool it gave engineers the
ability to start making some system
configuration changes to some degree and
application server changes and not have
to go through an ATAR cycle of putting
in a ticket waiting for to be scheduled
give me getting somebody to actually
perform that perform that task and come
back it says hey guys check it out does
it work that entire entire process was
extremely lengthy it slowed down our
ability to to pivot we were just weren't
as nimble as we could so going into the
cloud we're like okay let's let's take a
step back and let's understand where
what are we going to do to accelerate
application development but also
maintain the compliance requirements
that we need so what we decided to do
was okay within the count found confines
of the container go wild right and you
know those of you that have worked with
what the docker
knows that it's not really rude right
you get access to what appears to be
rude it's rude so and on the flip side
on the operation side we said okay let's
let's start putting some boundaries in
place because we don't want application
engineers to say hey I need more
hardware more CPU more memory because it
solves my immediate problem and it spins
up all the costs and you know we need to
put some some boundaries in place to
manage cost and risk so with our
traditional ops team we said okay so now
you know we don't want you you know you
guys talking to system engineers anymore
you guys have you know you guys aren't
maintaining systems per se you guys have
been building a lot of code to build out
platforms for
taury management or tools to augment our
ability to do deployments or you know
things of that nature
you guys are engineers because I've been
engineers all this time you just were
branded as an engineer so we said okay
why don't we take take a bit of a leap
of faith and let's start to transition
you guys into becoming more like a saris
as sarees being people that are
comfortable and and focused on
reliability right so these guys are the
folks on on our team that you know was
at one point system engineers or essays
transitioning over building out code say
okay we need to focus on for reliability
we need to focus on observability okay
so we're gonna go deploy a platform to
start collecting metrics we need to
start looking at how do we make our
infrastructure more portable so that if
we have specific issues we can move
things around so our sre teams have been
you know it's really a transition from
traditional ops into into more of a
software software space so for us we
have both and both vertical saris
beating within our bu we have our saris
and we also have a centralized SRE team
the centralized SRE team kind of works
in very closely with our vertical SRU
team they kind of act as what Google
calls and I want to steal Mike's term
here to kind of act as CRE s to our SRE
team so you know we have a perpetual
cadence of stuff that we need to roll
out and that we're constantly trying to
do we leverage a centralized knowledge
base of you know highly skilled
individuals that help us you know build
out out whatever we need to build out
mate because there's more people why did
we choose manage GK or why did we choose
to uke really comes down to priorities
like I said before we wanted to
accelerate
application development and that was
kind of our number one go and as Jason
mentioned it was really you know how do
how do we allow individuals to focus on
you know on the application and not that
so much the infrastructure so we decided
to go with manager
Jiki and focus on wrapping up our teams
number one number two redefine a focus
on reliability we wanted to make sure
that we start adopting some of the
process some of the practices around hey
if you build something it functionally
works on a laptop great you deploy it it
doesn't work in production what happened
you know so getting that instrumentation
in place getting that get getting that
instrumentation in place using those
reliability platforms that sre teams are
going to be building out feeding that
back into our organization our
engineering and parkouring organization
just say hey this is a priority you want
this to work
fix this right and often like you know
when you're revving feature sets you're
not really paying attention to to
reliability and I think reliability is
afterthought is how you get in trouble
right you don't want to think about
reliability in the middle of the Super
Bowl sorry cost management gke we've
been able to leverage the horizontal pod
accelerator autoscaler extensively so we
don't get that much traffic in the
middle of night we ramp down our systems
throughout the day we have you know we
do have a lot of peaks and valleys but
generally speaking we do also have a
consistent oscillating traffic pattern
people wake up in the morning they watch
their news they come online they they go
to work they don't watch TV anymore
they come to lunch they might pop on and
tune in to their favorite show catch 15
minutes of that and you know so on and
so forth and of course for us we have
multi cloud ambitions you know we we
definitely believe that you know you
shouldn't put all your eggs in one
basket that's why we build a
horizontally scalable platform that's
why we have focus we focus on SOA we
want to make sure that
you know if in an event that we have a
high profile in that high-profile event
temple events we do have the ability to
say hey you know this is not working for
whatever reason let's go somewhere else
considerations it's easy to use I think
most of you guys have have experience
which uke realize how easy how easy it
is to pop it in you know run a few
commands and next thing you know you
have your service up and running
frequent updates you know we we want to
make sure that we leverage two experts
as much as we can you know Google has
managed gke deployments forever you know
so we want to make sure that you know
the work getting as many updates to the
platform as we can without us having to
do any work
and of course we have the thorough
support of the Google engineering
support team and as well as our
Technical Account Managers they've they
you know they're constantly hit ping
saying hey how you guys doing do we have
any problems do you have any features
that you want us to evaluate having a
managed service allows us to provide
that feedback and have leveraged the
Google the massive resources that Google
has to do you know to do that work
challenges so I'm the problems guy so
the cloud wasn't that easy
so when we went from a data center as
Jason mentioned it was a single as their
own single data center signal phone of
failure moving into a multi zone
environment definitely had its
challenges so first when we were moving
over we said hey we have this monolithic
application what can we do to you know
tease this all teases up tease this
apart identify pieces that can
independently scale we can independent
of the attach cost to it so we spent a
lot of time finding candidates for
transition SOA obviously made it a lot
easier since we're already sort a
service oriented they made it made life
a lot easier for us to identify the
pieces that we could move over
we didn't want the lifted shift we
obviously went into containers and we
integrated with as many cloud manage
products as it fit within our
architecture there's some things that
didn't so we ended up refactoring our
code base roughly about 20 to 30 percent
of our code bases to be to accommodate
for some of the integration points we
want to make sure that you know like we
had this one service that we forked out
fit and it's really a kind of isolated
feature of a digital asset management
system it resizes thumbnails it's
historically the source code was built
to work on a file system NFS on the
cloud yeah I can have NFS I wouldn't
make people very happy if I could I can
have NFS but it's more appropriate to
integrate with objects tour so we ended
up gutting a lot of that code and to hit
the REC integration with objects tour to
Institute so that we can also have the
ability to the regional distribution of
our assets and you know all that fancy
stuff monolithic to micro services
straddling between the data center and
GCP we didn't we we didn't do a single
hop jump to two for our cut overs we
actually end up teasing apart roughly
about eight micro services and slowly
started moving our products up into TCP
so we you know we we had obviously we
had concerns about Dockers a doctor
station we had concerns about like his
crew Ned he's gonna work for us what
happens when things fail can't be
induced failure and how do we how do we
respond to those failures we had
questions about all that stuff so what
we decided no so we started taking
teasing of parties micro services moving
moving them up one at a time and just
kind of building up building up our own
skill set and of course we had problems
that look
so for us it was really more of a cut
over a cuddler problem so we'll we'll go
back to the thumbnail resizer we try to
pre cache as much as we could we knew
that so these are the dynamic resizes so
when you make a request it goes it says
hey I need this asset at this size it
goes and because it makes it and it
caches that asset it makes it available
it doesn't resize a lot of times so we
try to pre cache as much as we can we
loaded all of app so we ran through all
the permutations things were great the
applications work we were able to
validate that but we'd miscalculated how
many people are hot linking our assets
on Internet
so what happened was as soon as we
flipped over that flipped over the DNS
we had a tremendous amount of traffic
that just hit us so luckily because we
were on kubernetes we saw we we leverage
the cloud to allow us to wolf the cloud
has in all the resources in the world so
we just scaled out as big as we could to
absorb that traffic for a week or two
and then as the assets were cached we
started bringing down the cluster but
without you know having a fixed
infrastructure you wouldn't be able to
do something like that right you
wouldn't have all these resources at
your fingertips and you know so the
internal load balancer traffic
distribution is tupple based it does not
account for utilization on your back-end
so this one kind of bit us a little bit
we we are accustomed to a stateless SOA
application right so we expected this
this load balancer to just absorb our
traffic round-robin our traffic to our
back ends and awesome right well that
didn't quite happen so because your
tupple base your if you have connections
that if you have services that make
connections to these services and their
persistent connections they would they
would linger and it would stick and fix
be fixed on to a specific node until
that connection dies but because which
on optimize and not make a bunch of HTTP
requests we decided to use specific
connections and they just kind of
created a scenario where it was leaning
on two of our services or in this case
we have four four machines or foreign
foreign four pods and over time in the
beginning when the systems we started
the connection pools were hydrating you
know they made a bunch of connections
everything looked great
twenty minutes later we get this so
obviously what happened here was that
back-end services with persistent
connections lack the entropy necessary
for even distribution so we weren't able
to get even distribution with ILB as it
stands today we did reach out to Google
Google did come back to as I say it's it
is a feature request so if anybody you
guys have had this problem please reach
out to your Tam
we did but because you know we can't
live with this we obviously had to do
something so we decided to think about
what happens if we scale out if we
scaled out we wouldn't be we would be
able to create more entropy all right
because the tuples would have more
entropy therefore the load would be more
distributed but over time it will
eventually lean against one or two
pause anyway so that wasn't really a
solution application load balancing so
we said hey maybe we can just do this
ourselves
forget forget using the i/o be or it
allow the application to make request
directly to whichever back in service
well the issue here is you know because
we're in the cloud now you know resource
limitations is not executed I can have
any more we need to be able to support
Auto scale when you do Auto scale you
have to figure out a means for discovery
therefore those resources to play you
know that come online they become
available we have to be able to inject
that into our application do we really
want to reinvent that so lastly we did
we said okay maybe we've seen roll our
own load balancer we looked at products
like H a proxy and and a bunch of
solutions like that and we ended up
using the nginx ingress controller
and what this allowed us to do now this
still uses the ILB but what happens is
the engine X so the leaning happens
between IOB and and the nginx ingress
controller but within nginx is smart if
to understand that hey I need to make
equal distribution across the nodes that
I'm aware of and so the balancing
ultimately fixes itself right so more
problems zonal dependencies and coup DNS
so going into data center to multiple
zones when you have a relational
database and maybe some of you guys use
my sequel here yourself you have a
master you have a bunch of replicas so
you have to put the master somewhere
right so it's either gonna be in this
case a B or C and you have the situation
here now that if you out your
application is running in zone C and you
have a dependency on Zone A if zone a
goes away that's problematic right so we
need we need to kind of fix some of
those questions some of those problems
we looked at qu P&S like we said ok
kookiness it's cool it understands when
services become become available and
understands where the backend services
are it goes and distributes that but cou
dns has you know distributes across all
the zones so when that happens that
that's not really what I want I kind of
want a scenario that kind of looks like
this this is a work in progress so I
don't have a I can't sign off on a full
full solution yet but we want to be in
the in a in a position where we are zone
independent so if we're its own
independent it means a request that goes
into zone a stays in zone a gets
processed zone a and if that zone goes
goes away
cool we'll just cordon off that zone
drain everything out of dream our
back-end services all that zone and and
move on so in order for us to be zone
independent we have to move on to H a
data bases how to build databases so we
use Redis pretty pretty religiously so
we started thinking about a are we gonna
use the clustered Redis are we gonna use
Redis backed on centinall or do we just
deploy a bunch of different vertices and
just make the application aware that
they need to call specific specific C
names for you know so that the traffic
is stayed within the same same zone we
looked at clown managed products like
spanner and cloud sequel unfortunately
their regional so we didn't want who at
least cost equals regional and we didn't
want to be tied to a specific region we
wanted to be able to be in USGS and us
West we are using BigTable for a feature
set I'll come back to that but we
ultimately wanted B call neutral we
wanted to make sure that we selected a
database that allows us to span multiple
regions multiple clouds and you know so
we are evaluating cockroach DB to
maintain traffic within a single zone we
are looking at servers meshes we haven't
quite come to the point where we can
thoroughly talk about this year you know
we're still evaluating whether or not
sto or a other competitive competing
product is the right product product
approach but we are looking at service
matches to to do that and obviously we
have a lot of decisions to make lessons
learned plan for failure you know all of
our desire to be the only independent B
cross across regional multi-cloud is
because we want to make sure that we
have the capability of falling failing
out of a zone we have to be make sure
that we have a D our strategy really
focus our teams on setting up
reliability as a product you know you
got a build you got the instrument get
evaluate repeat everybody's
responsibility focus teams on with too
much instrumentation no way create a
feedback loop I think this is one of the
bits about building out a sre culture
you know it has to be you have to be in
a situation where you have a blame blame
free culture
allows you know instrumentation to get
surfaced and you know not have the
person that's reporting reporting the
issue be blamed for X Y or Z and it has
to be a well absorbed by you know the
product engineering organizations and
you know it's a team effort that's the
bit about SLO ASL is here and let Jason
talk about a Super Bowl yeah so you know
Hanson touched on a number of things and
I think one of the most important things
to really to emphasize is the cultural
shift when you move from systems
operations groups to an SRE mindset and
one of the first things that that comes
up is collaboration with Google and
they're an SRE team I I can't overstate
this enough that one of the benefits of
working with Google cloud is that Google
really does want to become partners with
all of the teams that come on board
their platform and that means really
understanding our application really
understanding what our problems are and
trying to help solve those problems one
of the things Hanson talked about with
the gke component is that there is a
virtuous feedback cycle with Google
where we give them feedback about our
problems with their products they go
back to their product and engineering
teams to really focus on a lot of these
problems and improve the services for
their customers so when we talk about
Super Bowl it's not just our team
getting ready for it it's Google also
getting ready for it so we spent months
working with the Google team getting
ready for this launch and what that
meant is working with our Tam our
Technical Account Manager working with
the the support team there at Google and
you know we really gave them an in-depth
understanding of our platform our
service-oriented architecture work and
all of the different platforms that we
were serving this con
I'm gonna pause for a minute and talk
about that because I think there's one
key differentiator in in our product in
comparison to a lot of our broadcasts
competitors that are starting to come
online and that is that we have over 200
affiliate stations that have their own
local streams so we're delivering the
local CBS station regardless of where
you are in the United States that means
that all of those stations have to be up
we have to have an Operations team and
we have to have a culture that makes
sure that all of our customers are
receiving the product that they they
want so the Super Bowl itself now I've
mentioned the 200 local affiliates so
it's not just one stream that we had to
worry about it was 200 plus separate
streams and this includes backup streams
as well because one of the one of the
most important considerations here is
mitigation and disaster recovery on any
event this size with your audience
expectations you better be prepared for
something to go wrong so what we saw on
the day the Super Bowl was greater than
17 times our normal traffic and you can
see how these requests spiked up during
the day of the Super Bowl
now we had pre-planned and as I
mentioned one of our big challenges
around these tentpole events is that we
can have very rapid request growth in
extremely short amount of time so always
being prepared for that
and not relying on Auto scale is
probably a safe bet so before the event
we scaled up 14 times our infrastructure
and over the course of the event I would
say about 3x of the additional scaling
was then managed by the autoscaler but
that gave us the ability to really
absorb that initial request hit then our
systems cook without missing a beat
on delivery now the good news here is
that calculating that scale was pretty
easy what we saw is that one Corps was
about 50 requests per second and we were
able to do the math and scale
accordingly so that we were able to
deliver at a really high quality level
some of the considerations that we had
to take an account besides just the
massive number of requests was scaling
our back in database systems Hanson
showed you a little bit about some of
our current challenges well what we had
to realize is that as we scaled
horizontally each of those cores taking
up 50 requests per second that we had to
scale those connections to our database
in order to handle the amount of
additional load than it was going is
going to receive so we had to consider
the upstream services and just the fact
that more pods is going to equal more
connections to those database systems so
especially when you have a single point
of failure like we did with our master
it's a really important consideration
when you're thinking about scaling up
your systems I'm gonna give this back to
Hanson all right so we've got some two
to kind of close off we have we have
some best practices let some press but
some best practices listed here
number one test your infrastructure
please because if you don't test it you
will never know so especially your
critical critical services work with
your tamp your temps are there to to
help you so if you for us you know we
had a situation where say hey we're
gonna get all this traffic you know do
we have enough resources allocated to
our accounts so that we can you know so
that we can we can scale to that point
if we need it to so work with them to
define you know what you believe is the
amount of resource or are the amount of
resources that you need and you know
they'll make it they'll make sure it
happens 100% engage
with your cre s and s Ari's treat them
as if they were part of your own team do
your architectural reviews make sure
they understand how each component
actually works where your single points
of failure are if any and where your
most critical components are share your
instrumentation you know the Google team
has a lot of interpretation behind the
scenes that can you know really augment
your perception on how things how things
are actually running from your your your
metrics and run books if you don't have
run books create them you know you you
have to plan for failure so if you are
going to get yourself in a situation
where you may lose a master database
have a run book run book entry in there
that says hey if I if this falls apart
whatever I do who do I call who they
scream at product development life
cycles we have to incorporate
reliability make sure you know it's
going to be a perpetual perpetual cycle
you're not gonna be able to get around
that and because the whole point of
planning for the planning for failure
disaster recovery you know at the very
least have a plan for us we have
ambitions of going multi-cloud hopefully
that will help us you know effectively
have a disaster dr dr strategy but yeah
[Music]